there's nobody more nationalistic  that has american pride as this  immigrant right here right  born in iran made in america and i found  that seems to be true with most  immigrants they're lucky to be here  they're happy to be here  like one of the conversations you have  with immigrants is you have no idea what  it's like over there in cuba in  venezuela in north korea with our friend  uh  yomi park i mean we've we've interviewed  these people you have no idea what's  going on over there so it you're talking  about the immigration policies it seems  to me  that it's the  americans who are born here  that are the ones who are a little  anti-american if you will the the far  left of the uh democratic party they're  the ones in my estimation they're the  ones basically saying oh like we're the  bad people we're the bad guys they're  kind of been indoctrinated or ingrained  into this school of thought where the  immigrants are like dude you have no  idea what it's like out there